[MUSIC PLAYING]
SPEAKER 1: OK.
So hi, everybody.
And excited to be here today.
We're here in Mountain View
with Michelle Gale, who's
joined us to talk about
the mindful parenting
life in a messy world, with her
latest book that just came out.
So we're very excited
to have Michelle.
A little bit about
Michelle before we get
started, and then she'll
be able to tell us
all about her messy world, and
also take questions for us.
And hello out there
on the live stream.
Michelle is a mindfulness
teacher and executive coach
specializing in working with
women, leaders, parents,
and organizations interested
in awareness-based practices.
She was previously the head
of learning and leadership
development at Twitter,
and spent her career
working in high-growth startups.
Michelle serves on the board of
the holistic life foundation,
and is an advisor to the Wisdom
2.0 Conference and the Mindful
Schools.
She has studied
mindfulness education
with Mark Holman, Jack
Kornfield, Tara Brach,
and the Search Inside
Yourself Leadership Institute.
So thank you very
much, Michelle.
And without further ado,
I'll hand it over to you.
MICHELLE GALE: Thank you.
Al right.
SPEAKER 1: Give it
up for Michelle.
MICHELLE GALE: Woo hoo!
We're here.
Hi, everyone.
And hello to the people on
the live stream, as well.
The last 24 hours of my
life have been really messy.
And I'm assuming we have a
room full of parents, or mostly
parents.
And so you did it.
You're here.
You can congratulate
me, as well.
It was amazing that I got here.
And it's a lot as a
parent just to kind of get
to where you need to go.
So I'm giving you a deep bow
just for being in this room.
And being that this,
we're going to be talking
about mindfulness,
why don't we just take
JUST a moment of pause.
I love we have the
gPause sign up here.
So you don't have
to change anything.
You don't have to do anything,
eyes open, eyes closed.
Just kind of
following your breath
a couple of times-- breathing
in, and breathing out,
and breathing in, breathing out.
And one more time--
breathing in and breathing out.
Now we're here just
a little bit more.
I am, too.
So I hear all
great presentations
start with a story.
That's what people tell me.
So that's what I'm
going to start with.
So this is a picture.
My son Brody is the
one in the hoodie.
He's 11.
This picture wasn't
taken that long ago.
And he had a few
friends at our house.
And one of the boys,
one of the other boys,
started talking about a tragedy
that happened in his family
many, many years ago.
But it was a pretty
intense tragedy.
And the other two boys listened
intently-- really listened.
They were asking some questions.
And there was a real gravitas to
what was going on in the room.
And I was just in
the kitchen kind
of hanging back, just
observing and watching
and kind of taking it all in.
And all at once, Brody,
my little guy, said,
I know what we need to do.
We need to have a
compassion circle.
And so he took them, and
one of the kids said,
well, I've never
done this before.
Brody said, don't
worry about it.
I'll tell you what to do.
He knows the deal.
I'm feeling very proud.
Now, every parent-- I'm going
to tell you these two stories
about my kids--
these are like the best ones.
Just so you know, this
isn't like life every day.
Let's make that clear right now.
But this was a good one.
So he walked them
through all sharing
about what was just said,
and sending good wishes
to this past place.
And they were in the circle
for a couple of minutes,
and then they went
on their evening.
They unlocked hands.
And they were going on a
night walk with flashlights,
and off they went.
But I was, of
course, as the mom,
I mean I was a little teary
eyed and a little stunned.
I mean, he's done things
similar to this, but not quite.
You know, he knew what to do.
In that moment, he'd
had the practices in him
enough through me--
and I didn't teach him
to go do compassion circles.
He just had the sense to pause
and to stop and to check in.
So one more story.
This is my son Tyler.
Again, not taken that long ago.
And he's an athlete.
He is extremely active.
He has two speeds--
full speed and no speed.
And he's had a lot of injuries
in his very short life.
And he was subbing
in a basketball game
with a friend of his.
He wasn't even supposed
to be playing in the game.
He actually was
there just to watch.
And they were short a player,
because it was winter break,
and so they asked him
to play, which he did.
I wasn't even there.
I had no idea he was
playing basketball.
And I get a phone call that he
had gotten pushed and shoved
and fell, and his
best friend kicked
him, broke his collarbone
trying to keep the ball in.
40 seconds left to the game.
So he was in an
incredible amount of pain.
The paramedics came and got him.
We ended up in the
hospital, of course.
On one side of us
in the hospital
was a meth addict
who's had an infection,
and was not very present.
And on the other side was a
man who'd been brought in--
and very rare, apparently,
I found out later,
in the emergency room.
The trauma unit was there
trying to keep him alive,
and he did not stay
alive, right next to us.
So Tyler experienced that.
And we kind of
paused together when
we realized this man had passed,
and sent him good wishes,
and put our hands on his heart.
He was in an incredible
amount of pain.
Apparently the collarbone
is only second to the spine
to break.
So we got home.
Very difficult to get him
in the car, to get him home,
to get him slowly
down on the bed.
I had to help him
go to the bathroom.
I mean, he couldn't do
anything for himself.
And when I finally got him
settled, here's the moment.
He's like, mom, I'm getting
to have the experience of what
it's like to be disabled.
I said, you are.
You are.
And he said, and
you're getting to see
what it's like to take
care of a disabled child.
I said, you're right, I am.
And then-- I'll try
not to get weepy.
He said, you know,
I'm going to have
a lot more compassion for
disabled people moving forward.
And again, you
know, I'm stunned.
And I got teary eyed with him.
And he said, why are you crying?
Of course.
He's 14.
Why are you crying?
And I tried to explain to him
in the best language I could
how remarkable it was that in
the greatest pain of his life,
for sure-- he's never
been in this kind of pain.
The darkest, one of the
darkest moments of his life--
he knows he's not going to
play sports for a few months--
that you were able to find
the learning and the beauty
in this mess that you're in.
And I told him, most adults
don't get there in a lifetime,
in a lifetime--
to be in that space and
to see the potential,
and to see the positivity.
So I love this image,
because we learn the most,
and we have the
most opportunities
to awaken and to
find our mindfulness
and to find our compassion
in the most difficult parts
of our lives--
in the cracks, in the darkness.
This is where the
opportunity is.
But we don't like that.
When things go wrong,
we want to push it away.
We want to push
away the unpleasant,
and we want to hang
on to the pleasant.
And that's normal.
That's what we do
as human beings.
And this is where these
beautiful practices
that I guess, I'm
assuming I'm preaching
to the choir in this room
and on the live stream,
that mindfulness and
compassion is important to you.
And this is what these
practices offer us,
that we can start to hold the
pleasant and the unpleasant,
the dark and the light,
the beauty and the yuck
in our lives, at the same time,
and be able to see clearly.
I love this quote, I think
goes so well with what I just
shared, by Rumi.
"Don't turn away.
Keep your gaze on
the bandaged places.
That's where the
light enters you."
And that's really just what
happened to my son Tyler
and to my son Brody
during the time
that they were
sitting in darkness.
And it was in this wounded
place that the light
entered both of them.
And we can all have
those experiences.
And we probably
all have had them.
Certainly when you
ask people, what
is the greatest
learning of your life?
Tell me about the time
that you learned the most
about yourself.
Very few people will point
to something fantastic.
They weren't at Disney World.
They weren't out dancing.
Usually it's something heavy.
It's a sickness, it's an
illness, it's a death.
It's one of those
things that brings us
to those heavier places.
So I'm not trying
to be depressing.
We'll lighten up a little bit.
And I love this quote,
as well, by Rumi.
"The cure for the
pain, is in the pain."
So we want to dive in,
we want to go deep,
we want to be willing
to go in and dive deep.
In the last 24 hours,
my youngest son,
Brody, the compassion man,
had a really hard time.
He has a lot of
learning differences.
School is a struggle.
We've changed schools
almost every year.
He's been having a
really hard time.
And he had the meltdown
of meltdowns yesterday.
And it took everything
in me to sit with him
and find compassion.
It was really, really hard.
But I knew the cure for
the pain was in the pain.
And I knew my job was to sit
with him, just like I did year
after year when
he was very young.
We didn't understand why, always
having a temper tantrum, always
on the floor.
We didn't understand,
we didn't know
at that time what was going on.
And he's a wonderful kid.
Super creative, non-linear, but
a lot of barriers to learning.
And when he was younger,
that was my practice,
to sit with him as the
temper tantrum went on,
and to sit with him
and to let him know,
I will hold this with you.
And that was what I tried
to offer him yesterday,
and that was what my husband
tried to offer him yesterday.
We will hold this with you.
We are willing to sit in this
pain with you, this messiness,
and hold this with you.
And there's light
in here, as well,
that you can't see right now.
Mindful parenting
in a messy world--
that's why I named
the book what I did.
So what gets in our way?
What gets in our way?
This tree is on the ground.
What we want is to be that
redwood tree standing tall.
You've probably heard
that image of the redwood.
The wind comes, the storm
comes, it kind of blows over,
but then it comes back up.
And I like to add that--
I didn't always know
this, but redwood trees
have very not deep roots,
very shallow roots.
But they're connected to
community around each other.
They're connected to
family around each other.
And I think that's a beautiful
metaphor for the parenting
journey, is that this is what
we do at home as a family,
no matter what that
family looks like.
We have shallow roots that
we're all hanging on to,
sometimes for dear life.
But we're all hanging on
to those roots together.
And that was what we were trying
to be with my son yesterday.
And this is what I think
is the big aha for me.
I've been noodling on this
statement for a while,
"Everything is fine.
Until it isn't.
And then it is again."
And I actually wrote
a blog post about it
not too long ago when I was
traveling over the holidays.
And this is what
gets in our way.
Because everything is fine, and
then it isn't, and then it is.
And we don't like
it when it's not.
When it's not, we believe
something's wrong.
And if we're always
believing something's
wrong when it's
not OK, then we're
never going to have those
opportunities to find
the light in the crack.
We need to be OK
with our not OK-ness.
Because let's face it--
how many parents in here?
Parents, raise your hands.
So pretty much everybody,
almost everyone.
Parenting is hard.
It's not easy.
I've been focused
on these practices
and working on myself and
doing inquiry and sitting
on my cushion and going
through trainings and teaching,
and I still have a hard time.
Parenting is hard.
It's not easy.
It's not meant to be easy.
And we're meant to fall,
and then get back up.
So here is what happens.
The movies-- we
all have this movie
in our mind of how things
are supposed to be.
We've all had this
experience, right?
We're going to go someplace
special with our family,
and we've been
thinking about it,
and we have it in
our mind in the movie
and what it's going to be like.
And then we get
there, and nothing
goes the way we planned.
And the movie's not
matching reality.
And what happens?
We go downhill.
We'll sabotage-- we'll
sabotage our experience.
So what mindfulness
gives us, and I'm
sure you've had this
experience, is to see the movie.
We see the movie playing.
Yesterday, all day with
my son, I saw the movie.
It's not supposed
to be this hard.
That's what I'm telling myself.
I'm seeing the
images of him calm
and going to school
every day and not calling
and the nurse not calling me.
And I have this movie of what
it's supposed to be like.
But I don't buy it.
I don't buy it.
And when we have our
mindfulness, we don't buy it.
And I love the image
of mindfulness.
This is something that happens,
something that we consider
is not good in some way.
And then there's our reaction.
And when we don't
have our mindfulness,
these two things are
right next to each other.
There is the bad thing, and
then there's our reaction.
And when we have
our mindfulness,
and we have our compassion,
this space opens up.
And we've all had that
experience of, oh, this time,
there was a little bit of space.
And I was able to make
a different choice,
and make a different decision.
And in family life, we want
to be watching those movies.
What is the story?
What is the story that you tell
yourself about your children?
What's the story that
you tell yourself
about your relationship
to your children?
And does it match?
It's an exploration.
There's no one answer.
But I encourage you to journal.
Journal on those stories.
What are they?
What are the stories that you
hold true about your family?
I have one about my
two boys, that they're
supposed to be super close.
Aren't brothers supposed
to be super close?
My husband and I had two
kids to live vicariously
through siblings, because
we're both only children.
So we wanted to see
what it was like.
That was our first mistake, that
we had this movie in our mind,
oh, we get to see siblings.
Well, they couldn't be any
more opposite in the world,
and they don't like each
other that much, is the truth.
You know, they have moments.
And so I've learned to just
take those moments for what they
are, and just keep planting
those seeds of love
and connection between
the two of them.
But the movie is not working
out the way that I planned.
And I work on being OK
with that not being OK.
Because it's hard.
It's hard.
So these are all
pictures of my family,
and we're happy, and were
smiling, and we're connected.
So what do you
think-- what could you
imagine all of these
pictures have in common?
We're on vacation.
And the other thing that all
these pictures have in common
is that there was
fighting beforehand--
not long before, just
a little while before.
There was arguing
and bickering and--
ugh.
The day from the beach
photo that you're seeing,
that full day was what I
wrote this blog post about.
And things happened, like in the
morning, I woke up, and I sat,
I did my little meditation,
we were on the water.
I'm like, oh, this is
such a good moment.
I love this moment.
And then my older son, who's
an adolescent now, woke up
and kind of came into
the room like, ugh.
You know, it was kind
of a grunt happened.
And I was like, mm, that's
not such a good moment.
I would have preferred
that had been different.
And then my son,
my two kids were
sitting on the couch
reading, not engaged,
but somewhat close
to each other,
both reading very peacefully.
And I'm like, oh,
see, this is so nice.
This is a nice moment.
And then it was time
to leave, and there
was an argument of who was
going to sit in the front,
and so that big
argument happened.
And I didn't like that moment.
I'm like, ugh, not OK.
This is not OK.
And then we're on the way there,
and '90s hip hop is playing,
and we're all
singing in the car.
I'm like, oh, see, we're
a nice, normal family.
Look at us having a good
time listening to music.
And then it's time
to stop somewhere
to get some food before
we go where we're going,
and no one can
agree on the food,
and everyone's got
food allergies anyway,
and my husband storms out.
We're at three
cafes to get food.
I'm like, it's just lunch.
Why does it have
to be this hard?
And then there we are on
the beach not long after.
But that's the way of it, right?
That is the way of it.
That's just parenting.
That's just family life.
And it's very easy, and I know
you have all thought, god,
this is a really rough day.
This is a really rough day.
But if we look at the moments,
like the moment by moment
by moment, it's
kind of like when
you're sitting in meditation.
And sometimes it's peaceful, and
you can kind of ease into it.
And then the mind goes
wild, and you're just
kind of trying to figure out
where you're going and hang on.
And then you kind
of settle again.
It's up and it's down, and
that's just the way of it.
So those are the
pictures you didn't see.
You didn't-- I didn't put
those pictures on Instagram
or anywhere.
I didn't talk about
how we were arguing.
I might tell my friends,
but we don't see that.
We don't see that out
in social media land.
We keep that to ourselves.
So all of these
emotions come through.
We've got the anger.
Anger comes.
And we're not happy, like,
we're not supposed to be angry.
Anger is not OK.
And the fear comes, and I
don't want to be afraid.
Or we don't even
realize we're afraid.
We're just reacting from afraid.
And then shame comes, that
mac daddy emotion that
dysregulates everything else.
And there's the shame that I
snapped and I raised my voice.
And what if you knew that,
even after all these practices,
I still raise my voice.
I've been trying not
to yell for 10 years.
And I do it less,
but I still do it.
And then it happens, and
immediately the shame comes.
But I have to know it's there.
I have to be aware of the shame.
This is the gift.
There's got to be
a little space.
So I see the shame.
And what if you
knew, what if you
knew how mean my kids
were to each other
and how angry that
made me sometimes?
And what if you knew
I was terrified.
I'm terrified that my kids won't
be friends when they grow up,
that they're not going to
be close, that they're going
to have two separate lives.
That really scares me.
But what we know is that
"awareness is like the sun.
When it shines on things,
they are transformed."
The wise Thich Nhat Hanh.
And so, just even what I
did right here with you,
the uber vulnerability, standing
in front of a room of people
and sharing.
All those things are true
that I shared with you.
I'm not making them up.
When we shine a
light on the shame
and the fear and the
anger, something happens.
It's like when we're
sitting in meditation
and we're thinking,
thinking, thinking,
and then we notice the thought.
Right?
That's our practice.
We notice the thought,
like the bubble--
gone.
We shine the light
of awareness on it.
And then we feel like this.
We're like, woo hoo!
You know, I'm aware.
I'm awake.
And we do that moment
by moment by moment.
And we do it, and we teach
our children to do it.
And we don't teach them to do
it by telling them how to do it.
We-- I teach my
children to do that
by saying out loud
what's going on for me.
So, say I'm in the
kitchen and everybody
is having a hard
time, and I'm finding
myself really irritated.
I might say, I'm
really irritated.
Like, I'm noticing.
My jaw is tight, my stomach
feels a little sick,
my heart feels a little
tight, my chest area
feels a little tight.
I need a break.
I'm about to say something
I don't want to say.
So I'm going to go away,
and I'm going to come back.
I'm going to go away, I'm
going to breathe a little bit,
I'm going to get a little space,
and I'm going to come back.
I don't do that every time.
Sometimes I blow it, and I say
something I wish I hadn't said.
And then I have to repair.
But the repair is just as good.
The repair is just as good
as catching it, sharing it,
making it explicit.
If we as parents are practicing
and waking up and becoming more
conscious, and we're
saying it out loud,
we're giving them this
experience to voice,
then they learn how to do it.
They learn.
So how, how do we
do this as parents?
And many of you may
already practice.
But I have something to offer.
So here we are, right?
This is kind of what our
lives often look like.
We're falling
asleep at our desk.
We're just spent.
We're completely spent.
We're trying to get bills paid,
we're trying to get work done,
and it's just hard.
It's hard to make it all happen.
So how do we do it?
How do we do it in
the course of a day?
Because this is
how I often feel.
I'm like, come on.
Come on, inner peace.
I don't have all day.
But we know that's
impossible, right?
Sometimes I'm like, why
couldn't I have just
been one of those people
that was born somewhere
and just live in a cave, and
this just would have happened?
That's just not-- it's not
the lives we're living, right?
We-- everyone here
in this room--
we're all working
parents, and we
have to weave in to what
we're already doing.
And this is good news.
"To experience peace does not
mean that your life is always
blissful.
It means that you are
capable of tapping
into a blissful state of
mind, amidst the normal chaos
of a hectic life."
And Jill Bolte Taylor wrote
the book "Stroke of Genius."
If you've never read that,
it's a wonderful book.
And I love this quote.
I'm like, oh, whew.
You know, we just have to
be able to tap into it,
and just touch, touch, touch.
We can have hard days.
We will have hard days.
I don't think you
could be a parent
and not have a hard day, whether
you have one, or two, or three.
So we can play.
I love these images,
because for me they all
point to things that
I try to do in my day.
I took on a practice
not long ago.
How many times have we
heard our kids like,
will you play with me?
Will you play with me?
And what's often the answer?
I can't.
Oh, I'm busy.
Or, I'm making dinner.
And I was hearing that.
My mindfulness practice helped
me hear, like, oh my gosh,
I say that so many times.
And so I committed to saying
yes for one week, just
to see how it would go--
every time.
Now, this was not
when they were three,
so that might be a
little different.
So you might have to say,
like, I'll give myself
10 times or something.
This happened when they
were a little older.
So it wasn't happening
like 10 times a day.
But I said yes.
I started saying yes.
And it was the best
little research study
I ever did inside of my family.
We had the sweetest week.
So I kept it going.
And I can't always say yes.
Sometimes I have to say no.
But I've learned to say
yes more than I say no.
Yes, I'll jump on
the trampoline.
I mean, jumping on the
trampoline's super fun.
There are some really fun games
you can play on the trampoline.
You know, yes to the card game.
Yes to the sword fight.
Yes.
And it might be that we're
just walking down a busy road.
That's a great
time to practice--
walking from here to your next
meeting, or back to your desk.
What if it was just
a mindful walk.
What if you were just really
paying attention to your feet
hitting the ground,
and that was it.
Or just following your
breath, or just even
like feeling your
hands swing from here
to wherever you're going next.
And when our kids are
having a hard time,
can we really just pause?
Can we just stop?
Can we listen?
And dinnertime is
such a good one.
You know dinnertime-- we
don't eat dinner together
every night by any stretch
of the imagination,
although I would love to.
But it feels almost
impossible at my house.
But when we do, and we do as
often as we can, we hold hands.
And we do this little hand
squeeze that goes around.
And it's this sweet
moment of connection.
Or we can be thankful
for how the food got
to us, the farmer
that planted it,
and the person that tended
it, and the truck driver that
came and picked it up and
brought it to the grocery
store, and the grocery
store person who took it out
of the truck, and the person
who put it so beautifully out
in the grocery store or
at the farmers market,
and mom or dad who went and
got it and brought it home
and cooked it, and wow--
we can be grateful.
We have a gratitude
jar in our kitchen.
It's actually a little too big.
I need to get a little
bit of a smaller one.
But it's a big
gratitude jar, and it
says Gratitude Jar on it.
And I keep paper and
pen right next to it.
And we'll just go through
practices of, every morning,
or at night, or if we have
friends over, just writing
a gratitude and putting it in--
that pause, just that moment.
So we build it into what
we're already doing.
We pause.
Just press the pause
button throughout the day.
And so the dedicated practice
that you're seeing more
in these images are important.
And research tells us
that retreat practice
and regular
dedicated practice is
very supportive for our
well-being and for our brains.
And, as parents we all know
that dedicated practice--
where we stop for 20 minutes,
30 minutes, go away for a day,
go away for a few days--
is not always possible.
When I started practicing
about 10 years ago regularly--
I was introduced
in college when I
was having a really hard time.
I went to a unity church
and sat every Sunday there.
And so that was my introduction
to guided meditation.
But I didn't start
practicing regularly
until I had a four-year-old
and a six-month-old.
That was when I
entered practice.
So I had to be really
creative of how I practiced.
And I remember one
of my teachers--
I was complaining to
one of my teachers,
I can never go to my
meditation practice,
and it just never happens.
And I was all grumpy about it.
And she said, well, tell me
a little bit about your day.
So I'm telling her about my day.
And I get to the end of the day.
And I'm like, and they always
make me stay in their room
at night, and I have to stay
there until they fall asleep.
And then I'm too
tired to practice.
And you know what's coming next.
She's like, why don't you
just sit in their room?
I was like, huh, why don't
I just sit in their room?
So I put a cushion
in their room,
and we made this agreement
that as they were falling
asleep at night I would stay
in their room, I would sit
and I would do my meditation.
I'd cuddle with them first
and do our little rituals,
and then I would sit.
And I'd say, I'm not leaving
until way after you're asleep.
I'm doing my practice in here.
And I did that for years
when they were really little.
So what are the things that
you're already doing that you
can weave integrated practice
that we're talking about--
walking to the office, or
walking down the street--
or dedicated practice
that you can even
do in one of your kid's
rooms, if they're super young
and let you in.
If they're teenagers they
might not let you in.
I'm no longer
allowed in at night.
We start where we
are-- wherever we are.
Wherever we are, we can
have a moment of practice.
And you all saw, as soon as we
came in, we took a few breaths,
everything shifts.
Everything shifts.
No matter how busy we are,
or busy our mind goes,
just a few breaths
brings us back.
So I'm just going
to run through some
of my favorite ways of
weaving it into my day,
or things I like to share.
Mornings are so wonderful.
And you don't have
to get out of bed.
I've done a lot of practice
with Jon Kabat-Zinn,
and he always says, lay
there, Savasana pose.
Just open your eyes so
you're not too sleepy.
If you can close your eyes
and not fall back asleep,
that's fine.
But when you wake
up in the morning,
just lay there and
follow your breath.
Do a body scan.
You don't even have
to get out of bed.
I will often also get up and
sit on my pillow with my husband
there, and I'll just sit and
close my eyes until someone
comes to bother me.
And I practice not
being annoyed that I got
interrupted from my meditation.
My bell didn't go off yet.
I'm not done.
Oh, I'm done.
It's over.
I'm definitely done.
The shower.
I've done a lot of
executive coaching.
I can't tell you how many
times you've heard this--
I have the best
ideas in the shower.
Why do we have the best
ideas in the shower?
We've paused.
We're in sensation when
we're in the shower.
The mind quiets.
So what if we did
that intentionally
when we got in the
shower, and we just
felt the hot water on our body,
and we just allowed ourselves
to be there in the shower?
One of my favorites--
I love my cup of
tea in the morning.
I'm a big fan of Earl Gray tea.
And usually it gets pushed
off, and gets pushed off.
I boil the water,
and my husband's
like, the water's boiling again.
I'm like, I know, but I
still haven't made my tea.
I'm dying to make my tea, but
I keep getting interrupted.
And then there's that moment.
To me it's one of the magical
moments of my day, that I stop,
and I just put my
hands on the cup.
And I smell it, and
I just give myself
30 seconds or a minute to just
enjoy the heat of the water.
I love this image.
When I saw this
image, I thought, wow,
what a great practice.
So I tried it.
And it sounds a little
hokey, but it works.
Every time-- for one day I tried
it, and then I continued it.
Every day, every time I
caught a glimpse of myself
in the mirror, or
in my computer,
I would say something
kind to myself.
I would send myself
some kindness.
Like, depending on the
day, it might have been,
you're doing the best you can.
I love you.
Whatever it might be, I'd
send myself some kindness.
And mindful listening.
I kind of mentioned that
a little bit earlier.
But if you practice
mindful listening,
it's just that
stopping and noticing
any thoughts that are in your
mind when someone's talking.
Are you trying to respond, or
are you really, really gifting
your presence?
And with our children,
particularly any older--
besides me, teenagers in here?
A few, a few teenagers.
Mindful listening, for all
of you that are on your way
to teenage-hood,
it's so critical.
In the car-- they
get out of school,
they get in the car,
what do most of us do,
from the time they're little?
How was your day?
What happened?
How was your test?
We start pummeling them
with all these questions,
and they, what?
Often, they shut down.
Even little ones will.
Sometimes the little ones still
want to tell you everything.
But certainly as they
get older, that's it.
So I've learned-- shh.
I pick them up, and I
just-- shh, nothing.
Just say, I'm happy to see you.
I'm so happy to see you.
That's it.
And almost always the
conversation will come.
And it's on his terms, not
my terms, and so it arises.
The car, use the car.
And, by the way, when
they come to be teenagers,
they sit in the back
with their friends.
And for some reason,
you're not there,
so you get all kinds
of good information
that you wouldn't have gotten.
Like, how do you not know
that I'm sitting right here?
Yeah.
It's so great.
And just-- mm.
Just shh-- don't say anything.
And I love this image, too.
Sitting in the car--
also drop-offs, pickups.
Anybody have to drop the
kids off or pick them up
at an activity?
Anybody?
Yeah, lots of activities.
In the car, beautiful place
for dedicated practice.
I'd drop my kids off to
jujitsu or baseball or wherever
they were going, and I'd
sit in the car for five, 10,
15 minutes.
Or a pick up--
just sit in the car for
five, 10, 15 minutes.
Use your Insight
Timer, Simple Habit.
On Simple Habit, I did a
seven-day series for parents
for just five minutes a day.
So if that's supportive--
I'm not sure if
it's free or not.
But it is on Simple Habit.
Headspace-- just put your
ear buds in, sit in silence,
get a guided meditation,
just sit in the car.
Oh.
And the smile, the smiles--
we can really take in
the smiles, the joy.
We can bring the
joy in more fully.
So I really encourage
you all to make a list.
It doesn't have to be right now.
But remember to
make a list of what
you do from the time you wake up
in the morning to the time you
go to bed at night.
I'll do this with
parents in workshops.
And I'm doing a
workshop here next week.
Maybe we'll do that.
Make that list,
and look and see.
Where can you weave in
a moment of mindfulness?
I mean, be really specific--
wake up, walk to the bathroom,
take my shower, make my tea,
make lunch for my kids.
Where can you weave in
a moment of mindfulness?
Because it really is--
we've heard this phrase--
it's like exercise.
It's like building a muscle.
We have to build that
muscle, and so we
have to practice over
and over and over again.
One of my teachers gave
me a centering practice
that I did 50, 60,
70, 80 times a day.
Depending on what my day was
like, I would do it more.
When my kids were very young, I
couldn't get away to a retreat.
In fact, I thought I was
the biggest fraud meditation
person, because I'd
never been on a retreat.
And I was bemoaning this
to one of my teachers,
and they really
stopped me in my tracks
and said, no, Michelle,
this is the gift.
This is what you're
going to get to share.
And this is what we all need
to learn as parents, that just
those moments, again
and again and again,
cultivates an awakened life.
And that's what we all want.
We want to live awake.
We want to be mindful.
We can feel the joys.
It's not just about,
I like to say,
it's not just about the sadness,
and it's not just about, like,
dealing with the
frustration and the pain
and the anxiety, which
it's so wonderful for.
That's what brought
me to practice.
I have a lot of natural anxiety.
I have it right now, and
it's not because I'm nervous.
I have it most of the time.
My chest is tight, my
belly is a little tight.
I always kind of feel like I
can't breathe in all the way.
I was just born that way.
And that was one of the things
that brought me to practice.
So it's wonderful
for those things.
And we can experience
the joys even more.
We can really smell the
scent of our baby's hair
when they first get out of
the bath in the morning.
We can watch them
play and see them
learning new things as they
get older, and just be in awe.
We want more moments of awe,
and practice brings us to awe.
And it brings us
to a fierce heart.
And here is what I think is
one of the most magical parts
of practice for anyone, but
particularly for parents.
Because our heart is going
to get broken over and over
and over again.
We're going to find
our lives and our heart
on the floor in
a million pieces.
And from those movies--
those movies that
weren't working out.
And we're going to
pick it up, and we're
going to put it back together.
And each time we put it back
together it gets stronger.
And the question we
all have for ourselves
is, can my heart remain
open when things are hard?
Can I have that
fierce, open heart?
And it's OK that it's cracked.
And it's OK that
it's not perfect.
We're not trying to
perfect ourselves.
We're trying to
perfect our love.
And I have a story
I'll read you.
I think we have enough time.
I love this story.
The first time I heard
it was from Tara Brach.
And it is from--
it's written by Richard Selzer.
It's from "Stories for the
Heart," compiled by Alice Gray.
And it's called "The Kiss."
"I stand by the bed
where a young woman lies,
her face postoperative,
her mouth twisted in palsy,
clownish.
A tiny twig of the
facial nerve, the one
to the muscles of her
mouth, has been severed.
She will be thus from now on.
Nevertheless, to remove
the tumor from her cheek,
I had to cut the little nerve.
Her young husband
is in the room.
He stands on the
opposite side of the bed,
and together they seem to
dwell in the evening lamplight,
isolated from me, private.
Who are they?
I ask myself, he and this
wry mouth I have made,
who gaze at each other and
touch each other so generously.
'Will my mouth always
be like this?' she asks.
'Yes,' I say. 'It will be.
It is because the
nerve was cut.'
She nods and is silent,
but the young man smiles.
'I like it,' he says.
'It's kind of cute.'
All at once, I know who he is.
I understand, and
I lower my gaze.
One is not bold in an
encounter with God.
Unmindful, he bends to
kiss her crooked mouth,
and I am so close I
can see how he twists
his own lips to accommodate
her, to show her
that their kiss still works."
So can we show
ourselves, and can we
show our children
and our families over
and over again, each
time we take a downturn,
can we show them that
it all still works?
So when the anger appears,
can we do that U-turn?
Can we notice the
anger, have that pause?
Can we do the U-turn,
and come in and explore?
Can we get curious?
What is this anger?
Where is it coming from?
What's it about?
As soon-- you know curiosity
kills anger in a second.
The second we get curious
about it, there's some space.
And then we have the
opportunity to do
something a little
more creative than we
might have done otherwise.
And when the fear
comes, we notice it,
it arises, can we
stop, do the U-turn,
and come in and
notice, ah, this fear.
John Kabat-Zinn often
says, and this, too.
And this, too.
I can include all of this.
And we get curious.
And then the shame--
can we do the U-turn and see
what is this about, this shame?
Can I explore it?
Can I understand it better?
And then we give ourselves
some self-compassion.
I'm a student of
Kristin Neff's work,
if you haven't studied her.
She was one of the original,
really the original researcher
on self-compassion.
And she shares that
what we need to do,
when we're in these states of
really being hard on ourselves,
is to be mindful, to bring up
our mindfulness, to realize
that common humanity.
We all go through this.
Everyone in this room,
if you look around,
we're all going through this
together, that it can be hard,
and it can be beautiful,
and it can be miserable,
and it can be fun.
Common humanity-- this is
your tribe in this room.
We're all connected
by being parents.
And then being
kind to ourselves.
And from the research
she says, always
put your hand on your heart.
So when I was doing that
little mirror exercise
I tried, if I wasn't in
too strange of a place,
to say something nice to
myself, put it on my heart,
or just anywhere on my
body, just to touch myself.
Let myself know, hm, a
little bit of kindness.
This is reality for most
people in this room,
for most people who are
listening on the live stream.
This is the reality.
This is how it's going to be.
It's going to be up,
down, everything's
fine, until it isn't,
then it is again.
Mindful parenting
in a messy world--
that's what we're living.
And we can respond
more skillfully.
That's what you hear
over and over again when
you learn about mindfulness.
It's all in the choice--
moving from that, we
live this autopilot life,
to get to choose, what
is my response going
to be in this moment?
So we can choose to go
down those dark places.
And sometimes we are going
down the dark places.
Last night, I was
kind of pooped.
I'd been with my son for hours.
And the compassion
just wasn't coming.
And my husband brought the
light for a little while.
I didn't have any
more light to give.
And that's OK.
That's OK.
And we're blessed
if we have a partner
that we can share that with--
not everyone does.
But we can go to
that side, or we
can shine the light of awareness
on the fear, on the shame,
on whatever is going on for us.
And I don't always get it right.
But these guys and these
faces keep me very motivated.
And I'm sure you have your
own faces in your phone.
I wish I could see all of them.
But this is why we practice.
We practice for ourselves,
we practice for the world,
and we practice
for our families.
And they are-- they will
bring us to our knees
in spiritual practice--
our children.
They will trigger every
undealt-with issue
from childhood we have.
And that's also
their gift to us,
because they point
us to our freedom.
They point us to where
the work needs to happen.
And I am very grateful to be
on this path with all of you
in this room and
everyone listening.
Thank you.
SPEAKER 1: Thank you, Michelle.
So we'll take questions.
Anyone have a
question in the room?
AUDIENCE: Hi, I'm
[INAUDIBLE] from Brazil.
I'm very glad that I'm here,
just to get your talk here--
MICHELLE GALE: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: --at the same moment.
So my point is about emotions.
How you call or you teach
somehow about emotions
for your children?
MICHELLE GALE: How do you
teach them about emotions?
AUDIENCE: Yeah,
emotional intelligence.
But not this kind of approach--
a more natural approach
for this.
MICHELLE GALE: Yeah.
Well, one idea that I share with
my kids is naming the emotion.
And there's some wonderful
research on this.
Matthew Lieberman, I think, in
2014 talked about just naming
the emotion, how that clears
the prefrontal cortex,
calms the amygdala.
So you teach them
just to name it.
And I think that's in a lot of
the parenting literature now.
Oh, you're angry.
Oh, you feel sad.
And it might seem a
little hokey to do that.
We do it more often
when they're young.
But we can also inquire with
them when they're older,
like, what is the emotion?
And if you can,
depending on your child--
my kids are kind
of used to it now.
Where is it in your body?
Locate it.
Is there a color?
What does it feel like?
So what we want is for them
to get to know their emotions,
and the body is where they live.
We experience them in
the body long before they
come into cognition.
And another little trick
with emotions that I also
like to share is time them.
So when they were really little
and they'd say, I'm so angry,
I'm like, wow,
you're really angry.
Let's see how long it lasts.
How long can you be angry?
And put on the timer.
Let's see how long
you can be angry.
And now it's a game, right?
So now it'll pass quickly.
Because now they want to
see how long it can pass.
But within 60 seconds
or a minute, it's gone.
And so they see, oh.
So what we're teaching them
is, it comes, and it goes.
It begins, and it ends.
Have you ever been
angry all day?
I'll ask them.
Well, no, not really.
It's usually not that way.
Is that helpful?
Anybody else?
SPEAKER 1: Hold on one second.
Let me get the mic.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
Thank you for being here
and sharing your stories.
So quick question--
like you mentioned,
there is this
structured practice
that you sit and
meditate, and there's
being mindful during
the day, and then
you mentioned a lot
of different ways
how to teach the latter one.
Have you tried to do like a
structured practice, meaning,
let's sit down together
and have a meditation
session with your kids?
MICHELLE GALE: With my kids.
AUDIENCE: Yes.
MICHELLE GALE: Well, the way
I came to teaching meditation
was actually, I went through
the Mindful Schools program,
because I wanted to teach
it to my kids at home.
And I ended up teaching
in their school.
So I taught in their school as
a volunteer for three years.
So they got it from me there.
And I found, at least
for me, anyway, at home,
to actually try to explicitly
teach it, most kids won't.
Most kids won't.
But I let them see me.
So if they come in my
room and I'm sitting--
I love, Jon Kabat-Zinn
tells this story
of his son Will Kabat-Zinn
is a mindfulness teacher
in his own right at Spirit
Rock and all around.
And he would say
he'd be sitting--
Jon got up very early to
sit, 4:00 in the morning
all the time.
You know, did his whole
yoga and meditation
and he says he never ever asked
his kids to sit in meditation.
But they'd come in, and
they'd see him sitting.
And he'd have a
blanket around, and he
said he'd open the blanket,
and they'd come in,
and he'd close the blanket.
And that image to
me is so beautiful.
And then they'd just sit
there with him in meditation.
So depending on your child,
some kids will eat it up.
Books are a really great way.
There's so many.
"Moody Cow Meditates"
I think it's called.
And I mean, there's
a whole bunch
of beautiful children's books.
And so reading-- we
did a lot of reading.
But explicit teaching, I
think it's the weaving in.
I think it's in the pausing.
Before my kids used to go to
school when they were younger,
they started walking alone.
And I was all freaked out.
I'm like, it's so weird,
they're leaving without me
and I don't like it.
And so for me, this was
a me-practice, I'm like,
would you guys be willing
to just hold hands?
You know, do our little
circle like we do at dinner,
and do a little hand
squeeze and take one breath?
Like, OK.
You know, they were
willing to do it.
And then, if I forgot,
they would ask for it.
So that probably went on
for three or four months.
Every morning before they
left for school, one breath.
So my encouragement
is to weave it in.
And if you have a child that
is really excited to learn,
then go for it.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: I have a question.
MICHELLE GALE: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: So tantrums--
what's the mindful response?
What would be a best
practice if you've just
got someone who's tantruming
a lot, or big time?
MICHELLE GALE: Yeah.
Well, I think there's
a few layers to that.
There's always like,
what's under the tantrum?
So that's always where, from
a mindfulness perspective,
where--
it's never the behavior.
It's always there's
some emotional reaction.
And what is the
emotion, and what
is-- nonviolent communication,
very nonviolent communication.
What's the need
that's not being met?
And I love-- I think
Dan Segal does HALT--
hungry, HALT angry,
lonely, tired.
You know, you can ask yourself--
hungry, angry, lonely, tired?
So to know what's under
it, what's causing it.
And if you can get them
to share, wonderful.
Sometimes in the middle
of a tantrum not always.
But then it's being able, like I
was saying earlier, to hold it,
so they know I can
hold this with you.
You're not alone in this.
We can be in this together.
And just that alone--
trying to stop it is,
unless, you know, sometimes
you're in the middle of a store.
And you're like, how
about a Twizzler?
And that works.
And that's just-- sometimes
it's just survival.
But if you've got space
and time, hold it.
AUDIENCE: Great.
Well, thank you so much.
I think we're at time.
Thank you so much, Michelle.
MICHELLE GALE: Thank you.